ils sont étudiants ou en recherche
d'emploi et après 106 heures de
formation ils pourront assurer la
sécurité de grands événements comme
Roland-Garros la Coupe du monde de rugby
ou les JO 2024
etc mais en fin de compte dès que je
suis rentré à la formation de formateurs
juridique gestion des risques
terroristes ou encore palpation et
formation au premier secours une
formation gratuite et rémunérée 11 euros
de l'heure 90 personnes seront formées
jusqu'au 30 septembre c'est devenu très
simple c'est possible et nous avons nous
ici à l'école européenne de sécurité
privée plus de 300 CDI à offrir notre
vrai obstacle en fait c'est tout
simplement de le faire savoir le secteur
de la sécurité recrute 13000 offres sont
disponibles dans la région mais il fait
face à des tensions c'est un secteur qui
dans ces effectifs a peu de femmes alors
que on aura aussi besoin d'elle pour
accéder à tous les événements et que ce
soit
fluide qui est pas d'attente pour pour
les femmes qui viennent sur ces sur ces
manifestations seulement un quart des
candidats sont des femmes alors qu'elles
représentent près de la moitié des
visiteurs plusieurs autres
établissements de la région devraient
prochainement dispenser cette formation